hello
my name is josh malias and i'm a senior
marketing product manager for miltoni
biotech
and thank you for joining this webinar
that focuses on the latest technologies
and resources available for immuno
oncology researchers
today we will be focusing on highlighted
products for immune subsets that are
increasingly recognized as some of the
key regulators of the tumor
microenvironment these include the good
nk cells the bad t regulatory cells and
the ugly macrophages
the agenda for today is as follows
first i will briefly provide some
background information about miltenny
biotech as a pioneer in immuno oncology
research and therapies
next we will discuss the importance of
reproducible tumor processing and sample
preparation
we will then talk about the fundamentals
and advantages of max technology for
isolating rare cell types and our
automated cell separation solutions
this will be followed by highlighting
the breadth of our cell culture and cell
analysis portfolios
and finally we will discuss our
translational and clinical offerings
empowering discovery and advancing
therapy
these are the words that most accurately
define our company's mission
which is to improve scientific
understanding and medical progress
by providing solutions that advance
biomedical research in cellular
therapies
and as a company we were able to achieve
this mission by our ongoing commitment
of bringing newer and smarter
technologies to immuno oncology
researchers
who are paving the way for longer and
healthier lives
miltoni biotech was founded in 1989 by
stefan miltoni
and the basis of max cell separation is
the column technology developed as a
part of his diploma thesis with this
technology being patented in 1990
the potential for max technology to
become a revolutionizer in the fields of
gene and cellular therapies became
obvious
in the clinimax cd34 reagent system for
selecting hematopoietic stem cells from
donor apheresis was developed
the clinical evolution of the company
has continued for over 20 years
including setting up a gmp manufacturing
site in federal germany
and in 2014 the fda gave approval for
cd34 isolation using the clinimax
together with the clinimax cd 34 reagent
what started out as a diploma thesis has
since grown into a global company of
more than three thousand employees and
well over twenty thousand scientific
publications citing max technology
annually more than twenty five hundred
patients receive cell products
manufactured using mil tiny biotech
technologies
allowing us to recognize our company
mission of advancing biomedical research
and cellular therapies
while initially leveraging max
technology to advance stem cell
therapies
much of our attention is now focused on
the field of immuno oncology
so
why are we as a company so focused on
this scientific field
in part it is due to the fact that
nearly 10 million people die from cancer
every year
meaning that cancer is the cause of one
in every six deaths
and it is one of the largest health
problems facing the world
in light of all the recent medical
progress
how is cancer mortality still increasing
over time
there are a number of contributing
factors and primarily these include an
ever-growing and aging population
so we can fully expect cancer to remain
one of the leading causes of death for
the foreseeable future
so what are some of the most common
types of cancers that we encounter
as shown in the figure below
a majority of cancer diagnoses and
deaths in both men and women can largely
be attributed to solid tumors this being
dominated by lung prostate breast and
pancreatic cancers
it is for this reason that the
scientific community and miltoni biotech
have been keenly focused on this aspect
of oncology
which is the targeting of solid tumors
the formation of solid tumors involves
the co-evolution of neoplastic cells
along with the extracellular matrix
tumor vasculature and various immune
cells
the conditions within the tumor play a
critical role as to whether the immune
system itself
or clinical treatments are successful in
eliminating these types of cancers
the dynamic tumor micro environment
varies drastically
even throughout the same lesion
and these various cell types within the
tumors can actively influence
therapeutic responses
and shape resistance
so what are some of these key players
within the tumor micro environment that
we will be focusing on
now as i just mentioned
the composition and characteristics of
the tumor micro environment vary widely
and are important in determining the
anti-tumor immune response
for example
certain cells of the immune system
including natural killer cells dendritic
cells and effector t cells
are capable of driving potent anti-tumor
responses
however tumor cells often induce an
immunosuppressive microenvironment which
favors the development of
immunosuppressant populations of immune
cells and these include myeloid derived
suppressor cells and c regulatory cells
understanding the complexity of
immunomodulation by tumors is important
for the development of immunotherapies
and we as a company are poised to
provide all the tools needed to better
understand these complexities
okay
so let's start talking about actual
research in the associated challenges
that are faced by those working on the
bench
we will begin with the importance of
tumor processing and sample preparation
in the solutions that miltoni biotech
has to offer
tumors are comprised of a mixture of
immune and cancer cells
extracellular matrices basal membranes
and vasculature
when dissociating solid tumors there are
three primary goals
the first being to reproducibly
dissociate your tumor into a single cell
suspension
the second being the preservation of
cell surface epitopes
and the third is to maintain cell
viability and functionality
speaking of solutions
what happens when you receive a tumor at
the end of the day
and you aren't prepared or appropriately
scheduled for all the necessary
downstream processing and analytical
steps
fortunately for researchers we literally
have a solution for this very situation
our max tissue storage solution has been
developed to allow for the optimized
storage of fresh tumor samples without
showing background effects like
activation or the induction of apoptosis
it has been tested and validated on a
variety of human and urine tissues
including not only tumors but skin heart
spleen brain and skeletal muscle
the result is the preservation of
viability
cellular composition and gene expression
giving you the confidence that you can
adequately prepare for all the necessary
steps to properly process your sample
when you are ready
when it comes to dissociating tumors
a combination of mechanical disruption
whether it be mincing straining
pipetting or the use of bead mills
along with enzymatic digestion
now these steps are often user and
provider dependent and can result in
rather variable results
our tumor dissociation kit has been
developed for the gentle and rapid
generation of single cell suspensions
from human tumor tissue
our kid is optimized for high yield of
tumor cells and tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes while preserving important
cell surface epitopes
this kit is ideally suited for the time
saving and reproducible preparation of
single cell suspensions in combination
with our general max dissociators which
provides the mechanical disruption
when it comes to processing your sample
just doing a mechanical dissociation by
itself can result in the loss of cell
populations which are closely attached
to the tumor interface
these tumor reactive t cells are often
lost and not recoverable
by using the tumor dissociation kit
we enable you to identify these rare
cell populations
this is demonstrated in the first panel
where you can see that significant
populations of interest are not visible
using traditional methods of tumor
dissociation
whereas these pd-1 positive flag 3
positive or 10 3 positive populations
are readily observed while using our
specially formulated tumor dissociation
kits
to build upon this we tested whether the
three enzymes used for enzymatic
digestion affect the integrity of cell
surface epitopes scoring from stable
moderate sensitivity to strong
sensitivity
our results show that a vast majority of
the more than 200 epitopes tested are
well preserved during these enzymatic
treatments
if your marker of choice is sensitive
contact technical support for tips on
how to adjust the enzyme combinations to
reserve your episode epitopes of
interest
as an additional example i will briefly
discuss the importance of epitope
preservation in the context of cd25 the
high affinity il2 receptor that is one
of the defining surface markers for t
regulatory cells
as mentioned
cd25 is a key cell surface marker that
is used to identify t-regs
though this epitope is particularly
sensitive to enzymatic digestion
making the identification and subsequent
isolation of these cells difficult if
not impossible
by adjusting the enzymatic combination
of our tumor dissociation kit you are
able to preserve this critical marker
giving you a much more representative
and useful readout of the cellular
composition of the dissociated tumor
there are additional surface epitopes
that are important in the identification
and isolation of both nk cells and
macrophages that need to be considered
when dissociating your tumor samples
whether it's
cd107b for macrophages and urine samples
or
anti-nkp 80 for nk cells in human
samples you can remain confident that
you are actually obtaining the necessary
information to proceed with your
downstream analysis
for a full listing of all the surface
markers that might be of interest to you
please visit our website to download the
comprehensive cell surface epitope
preservation list
once you have successfully
and more importantly reproducibly
processed your tumor samples into single
cell suspensions
the isolation of target cells is often
the next step that researchers take for
their downstream applications
first i will give a little background
information about max technology
and why we become the gold standard in
cell separation especially for rare
populations
max technology is based on three key
components
max microbeads the reagent
max columns
and the max separator the magnet
together they enable magnetic separation
of cell populations based on surface
antigens
this technology is a fast and gentle
method for the isolation of viable and
functional cells by labeling epitopes
with specific antibodies conjugated to
super paramagnetic beads
in order to separate your cell
populations of interest
only three easy steps are needed
magnetic labeling where an antibody
conjugated to tiny super paramagnetic
microbeads that bind to a receptor or
protein on the cell surface
magnetic separation where the cells are
passed through a column that is
positioned within the magnet
the cells labeled with the microbeads
are retained within the column while
everything else is washed through in a
gentle way
the flow through is called the negative
fraction containing the cells without
the ligand for the antibody or
antibodies
that were being used
in the aleutian step step number three
the column is removed from the magnet
enabling the magnetically labeled cells
so the positive fraction to be washed
out
this can be done either manually with a
plunger to gently push the cells out or
it can be automated using a vacuum to
pull the cells out or increasing the
flow speed of the buffer in the system
all three methods are gentle for the
cells and separate the cells into
negative and positive fractions with
exceptional purity and high viability
a frequently asked question is why do we
use columns in the first place
the magnetic separators and column-based
and column-free systems have a
comparable magnetic force
but the difference between the systems
is the column
this column is filled with small iron
spheres
each iron sphere passes the magnetic
force on to the next over a very small
distance thus amplifying the magnetic
force by ten thousand fold and ensuring
that the magnetic field is constant
throughout the column
this system allows for the minimal
labeling of cells with microbeads to
retain the target cells in the column
without relying on epitope saturation or
large beads that can interfere with
downstream applications such as cell
culture or flow cytometric analysis
the iron spheres have a cell friendly
coating that allows for the cells to run
freely through the column and can be
washed thoroughly to remove cell debris
and contaminants
all of this contributes to the fact that
max columns allow for highly effective
cell separation with minimal effects on
cells
if you would like to learn more about
the technology itself its benefits and
to see some data feel free to have a
look at the webinar recording select the
best with max technology on our website
the link will also be included in the
recording of this webinar or just search
cell separation in the video library on
our website
by leveraging the advantages of max
technology
we have developed a number of kits for
the isolation of nk cells t-regs and
macrophages from both human and mice
and while i won't go into the details of
these various kits you can rest assured
that we have the products and solutions
for the isolation of these key cell
types for most any researcher
when it comes to isolating cells
you can choose the cell separation
option or options according to your
needs
whether it's a manual process for a
limited number of samples all the way up
to a fully automated high throughput
cell separation instrument
miltoni biotech has you covered
now
while manual cell separation certainly
has its place in
certain day-to-day operations
our focus now is on automation
but why do we actually need automation
what is the advantage
automation reduces hands-on time and
frees you up to work on other tasks in
the meantime
tasks that cannot be automated
it minimizes variation between different
users in the lab or even good and bad
days of an individual scientist
and of course it minimizes costly human
errors
with standard protocols and minimal user
variation you can be sure that the
effects that you're seeing
are due to your assay rather than
artifacts
in short automation reduces redundant
experiments and allows you to focus your
time where it matters
there are two instruments that i would
like to highlight at this point
if you're interested in isolating
multiple samples in parallel the
multi-max family is a perfect fit for
this
24 magnets allow you to process between
1 and 24 samples in one run
or split your large sample between
multiple columns
this is achieved by using the ls ld or
whole blood columns
or the multi 24 column block for the
easy handling of 24 samples or one very
large sample like an entire leukopak
the multi-max 24 is a semi-automated
instrument and a good fit for many labs
that value easy handling but don't mind
manual pipetting
however
if you want full automation and maximum
throughput you'll love the multi-max x
which integrates a multi-max into a
liquid handling system
as mentioned the multi-max x is the
instrument for the high demanding high
throughput cell processing lab
samples are labeled and isolated
automatically
both for pvmc generation or
cell subpopulations from tumor samples
all programs are tailored to match your
needs so we don't leave the lab until
you're satisfied with the protocol and
the results
for many researchers
once you have isolated your cells of
interest the real work begins
this often starts with the culturing of
target populations for downstream
functional assays
so in the next section we will talk
about our cell culture portfolio which
includes activation
expansion and functional assay products
our max cell culture and stimulation
portfolio comprises a specialized and
versatile range of cell culture media
and reagents for cell stimulation
expansion
and or differentiation
products are available for human and
mouse primary cells including immune
stem neural and tumor cells
many of these products are available in
both research and gmp quality allowing
for the smooth translation into the
clinic
first we will discuss the media options
that we have from our cell culture
portfolio
for scientists that are working with t
cells our tex-max medium has been
designed for high performance t-cell
growth
high cell viability and consistency
under serum free conditions
it has been optimized for the serum free
cultivation and expansion of human and
mouse t cells and t-rex
our tex-max medium has a defined
formulation enabling reproducible
applications in human and male cell
cultures
it is produced without animal-based
derived components but contains
pre-selected human serum albumin stable
glutamine and phenol red
our research grade medium has been
developed based on our texmax gmp medium
again allowing for the smooth
translation into the clinic
for researchers working on nk cells we
offer our nk max medium which is the
perfect solution for nk cell cultures
and expansion from pbmcs or isolated nk
cells
the chemically defined xenofree
composition ensures reproducible results
expanded nk cells are fully functional
and can be used in any downstream
application such as killing assays
if you're starting your expansion from
pvmcs
the unwanted growth and expansion of t
cells and nkt cells is minimal
for researchers that are looking to
establish primary tumor cell lines our
cancer cell culture medium is optimized
for the efficient initiation and
expansion of human tumor cell cultures
from primary and xenotransplanted tumors
with standardized serum free
formulations
our tumor max media offers optimal
conditions for the generation of primary
cell lines by enhancing cell
proliferation without inducing any
genomic changes
the cells will maintain their
heterogeneity and tumorogenic potential
improving in vitro models for cancer
research and drug screening
t-regs are often functionally analyzed
by in in vitro by a so-called
suppression assay
for this purpose t-regs are co-cultured
with t responder cells at different
ratios in the presence of a polyclonal
stimulus
t-regs alone show a hypoproliferative
response whereas g-responder cells alone
can show a proliferative response
by co-culturing t-regs with t-responder
cells you can often see a reduction in
the incorporation of either thymidine or
the dilution of the cell tracking
reagent in the t responding cells
this suppression assay is performed with
a dilution ranging from a ratio of one
to one to eight to one the responder
cells to t reg cells as outlined in the
figure below
this product allows you to evaluate the
functionality of your t-regs not just
based on phenotypic analysis of surface
markers or cytokine secretion
in this next section we will be
discussing some of the critical aspects
that need to be taken into consideration
when phenotyping your cells of interest
especially in the context of the tumor
microenvironment
some genetic mouse tumor models
represent a gold standard to analyze the
effects of immunotherapy
as they possess a fully competent immune
repertoire
such analyses routinely rely on the
characterization of tumor infiltrating
leukocytes and their phenotype
however the amount and composition of
tills is highly variable and often very
low
complicating the flow cytometric
analysis of individual subpopulations
to make things more difficult
traditional hybridoma-derived antibody
clones used for flow cytometric
evaluation of tills show a tendency of
non-specific binding to immune cells
such as myeloid cells via naturally
expressing the fc gamma receptors or
induced expression of fc gamma receptors
on t cells in the context of the tumor
microenvironment
this can lead to an inaccurate and
biased estimation of till populations
to avoid fc gamma receptor mediated
background binding blocking reagents
including commercially available
immunoglobulins are used
this adds additional complexity to the
analysis as there's no defined consensus
on the best titer and type of blocking
reagents that is supposed to be used for
complex tissues like tumors in addition
blocking reagents increase staining time
and hinder the ability to scale up or
automate multi-sample analyses
here i'm describing the benefits of
using our re-affinity recombinant
antibody clones for the analysis of
different till populations
reaffinity antibodies provide several
benefits
over hybridoma-derived antibody clones
for example a specifically mutated human
igg-1 fc region that abolishes their
ability to bind to the fce
gamma receptor
this enables more reliable and
reproducible flow cytometric analysis
so i'd like to take a brief moment to
describe a little bit about our
re-affinity antibodies
our re-affinity antibodies are
recombinant antibodies that provide
superior lot to lot consistency and
purity compared to mouse or rat
hybridoma-derived monoclonal antibodies
they have been recombinantly engineered
to produce highly specific antibodies
that require no fc blocking
and additionally
they have the same igg-1 isotec
requiring less isotype controls
the manufacturing process of re-affinity
recombinant antibodies ensures high
performance based on the following
aspects
they are derived from a defined dna
sequence which encodes only one type of
heavy and light chain ensuring high
antibody purity
production is under biologically and
chemically defined standards
that result in
high lot to lot consistency
analytical biochemical and cell-based
testing of every lot ensures you're
going to get the highest quality most
reproducible antibody possible
all reaffinity recombinant antibody
clones contain the same specifically
mutated human igg-1 sequence as their
constant region
this offers the possibility to work with
only one type of isotype reducing the
complexity of experiment planning and
saving time as well as money
hybrid
monoclonal antibodies on the other hand
are composed of antibody isotypes
derived from different species and
therefore require multiple isotype
controls
this complicates not only the management
of reagent inventory but also panel
design when setting up experiments
all reaffinity recombinant antibodies
contain a specifically mutated human
igg1 sc region which abolishes their
need to block or to bind fc gamma
receptors
this allows for background free analysis
and eliminates the need for additional
blocking steps such as using an fcr
blocking reagent
one of the product highlights that i'd
like to draw attention to in our cell
analysis portfolio is our mdsc detection
kit
now myeloid derived suppressor cells are
a heterogeneous group of mononuclear
myeloid cells with
different immunosuppressive as well as
disease-promoting functions
in healthy volunteers they're found in
relatively small numbers but can expand
considerably in pathological conditions
depending on the type and stage of
disease the mdsc population might be
present in different maturation phases
validated unambiguous phenotypic markers
for mdscs are still lacking and
therefore various combinations of
specificities are used for their
identification
the mdsc detection kit is intended to be
used for the standardization and
simplification of flow cytometric
analysis of subpopulations of mdscs
described thus far
for greater flexibility the product
configuration also allows
the extension of the analysis panel with
additional specific specificities of
interest
examples being cd10 or cd66b
the mdsc detection kit has been designed
for the detection of circulating mdscs
and cell suspensions of pvmcs
and might be used for the analysis of
other starting materials such as whole
blood lysed whole blood or single cell
suspensions from human tissues such as
tumor cells
so finally i would like to briefly
mention a few key aspects of our
translational and clinical offerings for
those that are looking to take their
research to the clinic
as an innovative biotechnology company
we at miltoni biotech offer cutting edge
technologies and high quality products
to support your immuno oncology research
whether you are interested in studying
immune cells or cancer cells from the
tumor micro environment
or cellular models for the validation of
novel immunotherapeutic agents
check out our applications page for the
respective cell types
whether they're engineered t cells for
research
macrophages or modics nk cells or tumor
infiltrating leukocytes
to find relevant application data and
protocols based on our immuno oncology
products
moreover
we offer clinical scale immuno oncology
products for the easy transition of your
research workflows into the clinic
i'd like to thank everyone for attending
this webinar and for additional
information please visit our booth here
at the lab roots immuno oncology virtual
event or our website for all the tools
and solutions needed to advance your
potentially life-saving research
thank you and keep up the good fight